welcome to this video I'm playing would
sorry would matter would pouch food
pusher would push are not so easy for me
to pronounce that 2010 from the US we
got a French French steinitz variation
hmm yeah there are many lights him there
should be seven as a recent development
I'm not sure that I'm really appreciate
all the ideas behind the smooth but try
to play it anyway I know that they
oftentimes play with be sick okay page
for interesting very early age form
hmm
hmm well I have not cancelled short
maybe this is in fact a good idea if he
takes Knight eggs then he's got terrible
weaknesses on g44 so he probably will
not take and if he doesn't I think I
have a good locate yeah on the Kings
side I could play age five very cool it
keeps the kingside closed why not why
not the only issue now some something
something really bad ethnic the center
let's hope but it does not have any any
sacrifice or something okay g6 yeah
boots the age 5 195 I'll just take it
are interesting I don't know it is so
terrible i mean i got i get i get to I
know evil you will give this check at
you take and Knight f6 isn't this some
quite nice for me I don't know this
looks pretty pretty nice in my book if I
tell you ever play here yeah let's let's
play that first I think I can do that
knight c6 oh no I can play night before
you if I want night before
I can just take here there's a simple
and good and here 5c form if I please
see for and give this check yeah this is
quite strong but if I have many good
moves here night before also not bad he
needs to go back to the window ok ok
let's play one of the one of the good
lines he needs to go go in here and twin
before now am check now if he goes king
of 1 i'm going to take on g three years
hmm hmm my main idea was c3 queen bee to
look you have this one night x h eight
texts here just ignores all that
okay when Jax exchange and I just I just
won this pawn do I want to take him as
God wrote you one rupee g8 possibly ok
don't I don't really need to so what
what is this i'm horned up right no i'm
not i'm 17 again six and i have for this
idea be 5a 5b for weather pass on the
queenside and at this very strong knight
on e4 of course i don't really want to
take it feels unnecessary to me to give
them any counter play the night only for
is so strong okay if it takes
palm tanks you know I can do that if it
takes politics at Bishop g62 at five
it's quite quite nice
be sure to do successful probably a good
idea I still think you should take it
home yes he did to take it I 55 forgot
about at five of course how stupid is
that f5 and Bishop g5 so this was some
of the phone hmm what the jack yeah out
of a completely winning position I
allowed him to get so much play really
idiotic this was bad Wow my player mean
and maybe it's still okay
yeah it's probably still okay and turn
before now yeah I guess so 85 if he
texted i'm going to play five let's
still have the sea pond still it was by
far not the the best way to lame and I
could have played Bishop c4 maybe
yeah I'm a man wait really like to like
to get rid good rule of their six porn
come on let's just don't just take this
50 seconds
Jarren
yeah I need to get to get the pawns
moving him now I completely misplayed
this wow really really bad default check
now okay maybe I get something
this wasn't the best one to be played
check check ah what the heck no oh no
why did I take with the poems an idiot
no yeah if only this square root before
made let's know it I thought it was a
late wow wow this is a bad game check 20
seconds left ty morning
I shall 82 I can just take it wow what
the heck am i doing in this game this is
probably one of the worst blitz games
ever played here video ah what the heck
check check check Jim wait for Fitz on
time yeah what is this is a lost yeah I
guess so where the spawns yeah ok one on
time but what the heck what a crap game
wow this is really a mountain below
every thought I was made here even and I
mean especially considering that this is
like a position that white could could
resign with a clear conscience I'm just
playing this so badly allowing this and
so on data it gets really really tricky
and now I must play a five of course it
okayed it still keeps a better game but
I simply don't play five and waits for
so long yeah around here white ass of
course better but it's still very tricky
check aunty I must take her with the
rook is but of course I overlooked
chatham this is actually winning the
computers on minus five fair probably
the porn searches promote with good play
check even this is winning but only if i
go to g6 yeah this is just the ultimate
ultimate off-road blitz game i probably
manage to like him
at least 10 question marks if not more
alright thanks for watching